could you work as a physician oh yes in
the ghetto
and it yet there was a situation which I
don't think was ever repeated in history
and they will never will never will
happen again the life situation people
people were wearing two or three pieces
of clothing one top layer because if
they have to move to go somewhere else
that's what they could carry and spread
this became even worse later when I left
Warsaw and went to grab a ship again
that's why this fantastic and normals
incredible epidemic of typhus and die
for it
if if you didn't have immunity from
previous exposure to types a tie for it
you had to get it because lights were
covering everything later on the crew be
a chef I saw once something that I still
see it after after what 4050 years four
years this poor man came over and he
started I had a record office but three
feet by five a little space this man
came over spitting blood or something
we're close is probably I don't remember
and I said undress and I was sitting
here in one corner of the room he goes
he was coming in from the door through
the door and he started to undress
integral of one coat of Earth's outer
coat than a jacket and then I best then
another jacket and then several pieces
of clothing and he just kept putting it
on the floor
and then I saw them I said where we
don't know the bothers you what is he
wearing
I took up my glasses him me aside and
there was a coat completely a complete
coat of thousands of lies covering his
body myself might grace you know they
were shining
it was something that after 40 years it
still haunts me this sight of a man
covered with handles may beat out
thousands probably lies crawling over
him in a know each other at that time
they already had kept out of that group
I think 10 people or something which
they kept so they could bury those that
they were going to shoot so it is on our
own good that means I am accepted to be
spared from the rest I said my day first
I said my man is faster - faster he knew
her from town oh yeah then I had the
courage races - to our fear I have here
my parents not my brothers first I said
my brothers so he must have promised a
burglar to make an exception
so Phoenix came out good except then Sam
came out and Sam look like hell he was
thin he was gray he was unshaved he
looked for the years it altered him his
age you should sir he's a - [ __ ] he's
weak he won't be able to work nice a
strong mafia leave it to me in three
days with good food you look at for this
Idol I create then I had the guts to say
want my elder and my day that means my
parents and Henry Oh Andy - Andy was
accepted
he heard the word word Alton he says bus
what old Jews to him well my Nana had to
be old Jews I said they're not all good
and all of a sudden ITC a fury in his
eyes and he says next bed so break
somehow orphans in other words the whole
deal is off back to the group we should
go back to the to the whole thing and be
treated like the rest
and that's it he stand there oh and
while he was selecting the fight the
five of my family
he also selected three or four and he
will know better young people from the
group to join us but when he got mad
when I asked about my parents he says
sir eat some - back three - the bunch no
more deal is all kind of so we stand
there and waiting what to do then the
chief of Gestapo the little man who was
the chief phenomenal chief but Edna was
the the egg is a fusion he came down and
he won because then they were making the
last preparations to take all the people
out into the into the trucks and take
him away to be shot and he saw this
group our group still standing separated
the way the way Edna selected us I was
mad either here what barod what what are
these doing here
so a Polish policeman a uniform I
couldn't understand the world German he
says Edna that means Abner selected us
and the middle guy probably was scared
for him as ever to be alway because he
was a pathological killer I'm not sure
oh yeah good oh we should go up the
stairs to the building because he was
going to take care of the rest
try not to be emotional
in my burger
she turned to me she says erotic and
save the children
and I saw my father helping her by the
elbow to go through the gate to be put
into the truck
they were killed at night
anyway we went to sleep and this ended
in destroy and it about five o'clock
5:30 they stopped the guards came in of
off to get up they lined us up in the
bottom five by five or five by five
that's the way were you have marched by
the way this is what's called the death
march whoever couldn't follow the group
was a shat on the road and left in the
road Felix - hey Felix no feelings was
left wounded there and we are standing
there I was in the first group of five
but me was a a dr. Shindell who's now in
Israel and three more and then five five
five five so we were a group about 200
people and then there was a yard in
front of the barn and the yard was
separated from the road by a low fence
and we saw I saw from a distance I saw a
plane coming down throwing a bomb on a
railroad station there was an American
or English plane and then all of a
sudden in front of the bomb on that main
road about 50 yards in front of me
attack passes going that away in other
words going towards where the Germans
were and I look at the tank and and I
saw that the the the star the white star
not the Hutton Kreutz you know
I don't know what it came to me that
this is not the job this must be
American and I yelled one word Americans
Americana and started to run to the to
the tank and everybody followed me the
Germans who were assembled assembled
around the barn and all some of them in
the barn
they took him another look at the tank
through their rifles away and started to
run behind the barn toward say the wood
to do what's behind apart some of our
people from the group run after them and
brought back pieces of some of the
guards actually pieces I didn't have it
in me I only went over to the tank I set
down on the ground
and the realize I'm free but who is left
who am I going to look for my family I
didn't know and the man in the tank
leaned over patted my shoulder and gave
me a pop bucket full of these Lucky
Strikes then I cried no matter what I
said here this step results and things
like that these are only words that try
to describe emotions feeling situations
whatnot but these are only words that
are a too feeble expressions of what
really they should mean you can't you
can't you can't
exterior eight from your deep well deep
hidden emotions you can't exterior eight
them and show them in words it's
impossible there are things that will
never be told because they cannot be
told